[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique d'ayrté france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec lydia
guirous ce essayiste et membre du bureau
politique les républicains fassent avoue
georges kuzmanovic fondateur de
république souveraine
invité sur ce plateau également françois
bernard huyghe chercheur associé à
l'iris spécialiste du terrorisme et de
la communication et christophe thévenet
avocat à la cour membre du conseil
national du barreau et président de
l'association des amis de charlie hebdo
qui va nous rejoindre d'ici quelques
minutes
merci en tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france et c'est à la
une cette semaine regarder les
commémorations des attentats de charlie
hebdo et de l'hyper cacher le 7 janvier
un commando terroriste avat et de
sang-froid 12 personnes au sein de la
rédaction du journal satirique le
lendemain une policière était tué à mon
goût
et puis le 9 janvier la prise d'otages à
l'hyper cacher de la porte de vincennes
faisait quatre victimes juives le choc
pour la france qui renoue avec le
terrorisme islamiste
cinq ans après la menace est toujours
aussi dépassé simplement des souvenirs
comme des graines c'est aussi toujours
la même vigilance face à l'intolérance
ou fanatisme à l'islamisme qui peut
faire des ravages
c'est aussi de montrer que la france a
fait bloc pendant cette période qu'elle
a été capable de ne pas se diviser
qu'elle était capable de se lever pour
défendre la liberté
le risque a changé la changer de nature
il était exogènes projeté depuis des
pays étrangers il est aujourd'hui
endogène en france quelquefois au plus
près de nous et donc c'est un message de
mémoire de respect de mémoire pour les
victimes mais surtout de prévention le
risque terroriste reste aujourd'hui dans
notre pays à un niveau particulièrement
élevé voilà pour le constat du ministre
de l'intérieur françois bernard huyghe
une réaction je vous ai entendu réagir
alors que christophe denis allaire avait
alors premièrement christophe castaner
ce ton bois un petit peu parce que les
frères couach et coulibaly était
français n'avait pas été fair la hijra
et le jihad au pays de cham donc c'était
tout aussi autant de jeunes que les
bonshommes au couteau aujourd'hui est
par ailleurs ce qui est très frappant
dans les déclarations de françois
hollande mais je vois pas ce qui pouvait
déclarer d'autres il dit nous devons
voilà nous sommes toujours aussi ferme
contre eux puis développe tout un tas de
mots en isme extrémisme les islamismes
le terrorisme et c'est donc on se bat
contre les attractions des abstractions
alors qu'on se bat contre des
organisations bien précis les néanmoins
on a progressé en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme selon vous très peu
enfin très marginalement en ce sens qu
on a progressé dans alors on empêche des
attentats de temps en temps l'autre jour
il ya un bonhomme qui rêvait sur les
réseaux sociaux de précipiter des avions
ou bien de prendre des voitures et qui a
qui a été pris donc c'était sait très
bien qu'on l'ait arrêté mais je pense
pas que c'était aussi dangereux
et les terroristes du 11 septembre on en
a on a des problèmes
de renseignements je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en parler on a des
problèmes de répression judiciaire
entre ceux qui rendent ce qui par ce qui
ce se radicalise en prison et on a un
problème de discours de rhétorique c'est
à dire on ne sait pas faire de la
déradicalisation et on ne sait pas très
bien quoi leur répondre
en dépit du fait que on est pour
certaines choses d'excellents services
de police qui ont très bien compris la
chose on a vu en tout cas ces derniers
jours plusieurs tentatives ou même
attaque terroriste au couteau attaques
isolées émanant d'individus
le dernier en date c'était une femme
vêtue d'une burqa à la gare d'austerlitz
qui avait un couteau elle a été arrêtées
préventivement lydia guirous ce il faut
se méfier tout aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je suis féministe pour
l'égalité homme femme et je pense que
les femmes déjà 19 mettrait les faits
mais évidemment et parfois ce sont elles
qui qui motivait l'ont embrassé cette
idéologie ans avant exactement de quoi
il s'agit quand elles sont parties en
syrie elle ne sont pas partis comme des
victimes mais comme des actrices
déterminé alors la salade est là bien
sûr on revient sur ac est quand même
rappeler l'épisode près de notre dame de
paris
cette voiture avec je crois une douzaine
de bonbonnes de gaz qui était stationnée
qui aurait pu exploser et qui aurait
créé un drame au coeur de paris
incroyable c'était trois femmes dont
deux très jeunes
évidemment il faut traiter les femmes
avec la même sévérité que les hommes
moi je trouve que cinq ans après charlie
hebdo on a encore des pudeurs pour
nommer les choses
vous avez encore certains responsables
politiques qui n'osent pas dire qu'il
s'agisse de terrorisme islamique
1 on dit la barbarie l'obscurantisme le
terrorisme mais on ne dit pas très
clairement les choses et après on a
entendu pendant cinq ans certaines
personnes parler de déradicalisation
mais moi je ne crois absolument pas je
ne crois pas qu'on puisse dès
radicaliser des individus radicalisés et
il ya eu beaucoup de charlatans de la
déradicalisation qui ont été sur les
plateaux télé qui ont fait leur beurre
et je crois qu'il faut sortir de toute
cette naïveté avoir une répression
beaucoup plus forte
je suis très inquiète la jeune femme
dont vous parlez elle a été relâchée
je suis très inquiète quand je vois le
shaq presse retenue contre elle
mais quand je vois que les peines sont
très légères quand je vois que certains
appellent au retour des djihadistes de
rapatrier certains tchadiens
je suis très inquiète parce que derrière
la justice n'est pas assez sévère et et
ces personnes sont déterminés et
passeront à l'action dès qu'ils
sortiront de prison parce que leur
détermination d'un n'a pas du tout n'a
pas faibli vous parlez de détermination
on a un enregistrement qui est paru
cette semaine qui a été diffusée dans
les médias c'est les discussions qu'a
eues salle abdeslam l'ancien terroriste
notamment des attentats des terrasses et
du stade de france
il discutait camp lorsqu'il était en
prison en belgique donc avant de venir
en france avant d'être incarcéré en
france avec ses co-détenus et et vous
voyez ce qu'il disait à l'époque la
journaliste me dit vous trouvez normal
qu'il y ait des barrages comme ça j'ai
dédié
oui c'est normal vu les circonstances il
faut bien renforcé les barrages
alors ça c'est une réponse alors qu'ils
étaient en voiture il est en cavale
recherché par toutes les polices de
france et belgique et ils tombent sur
des journalistes qui l'interrogent sur
les barrages il se fait arrêter un petit
peu plus tard dans cette même dans ce
même véhicule par les policiers qui
fondera contrôle et finalement le laisse
passer ça montre quelques failles
néanmoins non dans justement à l'époque
alors qu'il était recherché on l'a on
l'a on l'a vu deux fois et on l'a laissé
retour d'angers ce qui n'était pas blanc
bleu avant fin il avait déjà l'été
assiette
alors oui ça ça prouve des failles c'est
évident ce retour après un événement
aussi énorme que la soirée la soirée du
bataclan mais ça je crois que ce sont
des erreurs des erreurs bureaucratiques
enfin ça ne les excuse pas sont des
négligences ce sont des cas et quand
elle est partie j'ai refusé on se
demande à quoi ça sert qui est qu'on est
tellement d'électronique allemande
portrait-robot tellement de milliers de
gens se ficher s'ils peuvent traverser
comme ça en profite en valeur mais ça on
est dans la faute
humaine alors qu'il me semble que nous
avons eu des fautes idéologique et
organisationnelles qui sont plus graves
ce qui n'empêche que voilà il faut
botter les fesses aux douaniers qui ont
fait ce genre de crise mais devich des
progrès ou pas dans la lutte
antiterroriste selon vous mais non je ne
crois pas je suis donc d'accord avec
monsieur bernard hugues
je suis très étonnée d'avoir quand même
un président de la république françois
hollande est un actuel ministre en
exercice qui visiblement ne maîtrise pas
très bien le dossier et ce qui est un
ski est un souci donc les cancans
maîtrise pelle dossier dans quel sens
bas depuis les attentats charlie hebdo
il est quand même 250 et 255 personnes
quand tu es tu en france et le bataclan
et unis s'il ya eu un quart des musiques
l'hyper cash les errements bon et on
sait en fait quels sont les moyens pour
lutter contre le mal le terrorisme là
vous avez raison ce sont les risques sur
terroristes en tout cas non lutte contre
des gens qui pratiquent le terrorisme le
terrorisme est un concept lutte pas
contre un concept c'est absurde on tue
on lui doit effectivement plus sur
désorganisation or ces organisations
doivent être connus on doit enquêter et
et les poursuivre et il ya deux moyens
par excellence qui sont le renseignement
humain et là on pèche par
l'acculturation là aussi vis-à-vis des
etats-unis kipré qui préfèrent le
renseignement électronique
d'où d'ailleurs ce genre d'erreurs parce
qu'on oublie on oublie c'est la pratique
du du luxe du regard de l'oeil on a deux
joueurs comme ça les mains par rapport à
dire quelqu'un parce qu on est un peu
trop habitués dont compris j'ai tourné
qu'à l'humain c'est la doctrine des
états unis au renseignement
et alors qu'on avait un la france était
plutôt respecté pour son renseignement
humain qui est qui coûte plus cher
politiquement parce que ça non est ce
que les gens soient formés parlent des
langues très très fort mais parce que
doit être maîtrisée de nombreux sujets
parler des langues ça filtrer et
risquait de périr
alors qu' aucun risque à suivre des
conversations
un téléphonique ou deux yémen ensuite
c'est la justice il ya en france alors
que ça fait quand même on commémore ce
tragique événement on aurait eu tout le
temps avec deux présidences de créer un
second parquet antiterroriste n'a
toujours qu'un sur deux n'arrive pas à
suivre tous les dossiers et qui a un
effet pervers en raison du
fonctionnement de la magistrature c'est
comme vous avez comme vous dites que
vous êtes juge antiterroriste quand vous
avez fait vous disant vous devez par les
règles administratives du fonctionnement
de la magistrature changé on avait un
cancer et vidic on a des très bons qui
sont bondées exemple celui qui se
retrouve hélas locative mais il se
retrouve à s'occuper après 10 ans ilan
experts on a un bon on a un excellent
chasseur de têtes de terroristes
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas où on va
raconter tous ceux qui ont été arrêtés
sans avoir agi et on
il est envoyé s'occuper de divorce à
lille ce qui est complètement enfin ce
qui est qui est ridicule
et puis on ne s'occupe pas des pas tant
que ça du financement si on a toujours
des relations en terme de terrorisme
incestueuses avec le qatar ou l'arabie
saoudite
on a on la laisse finances et bien des
organisations
cultuelles et culturelles tout à fait
étonnante dans nos cités on ne sait s'il
va me radicaliser
parce que le combat doit se mener sur le
terrain français c'est bien c'est bien
ça le est la dernière chose est très
étonnant comment on aurait pu en cinq
ans faire des maîtres les les
terroristes ou ceux qui sont supposés
pouvoir faire des actes terroristes à
l'isolément ou dans des prisons
spécialisés où ils sont entre eux plutôt
que de les mettre avec des droits
communs et où il forme les droits
communs à passer à autre chose qui
congolaise qu'au bout de cinq ans qui va
s'aggraver avec les retours alors ces
questions vous parlez des retours c'est
que si on avait des prises des prisons
spéciales du cas il n'a été question que
donc ils ne prennent pas conscience de
l'être en tout cas au niveau européen
apparemment nicole belloubet on en a
parlé
une prison au niveau européen pour
accueillir justement ce tous ces
djihadistes susceptibles de revenir de
la guerre en irak ou en syrie écoutez le
nicole belloubet elle évoque la
possibilité maintenant du retour en
france de ces djihadistes alors que le
gouvernement jusqu'à présent avait une
ligne inverse jusqu'aux récentes
évolutions nous pensions à la
possibilité de mettre en place avec
d'autres états européens
un tribunal mixte en irak mais la donne
a changé et dans ce cas là il s'il n'est
plus possible de les juger sur place
je ne vois pas d'autre solution que de
rapatrier ces gens en france tous
combattants terroristes qui seraient
rapatriés serait judiciariser comme nous
l'avons toujours fait et nous
accueillons un sur ce plateau à
christophe thévenet avocat et membre du
collectif de charlie hebdo merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoints sur sur
ce plateau
messieurs thévenet ont parlé de la
menace terroriste depuis les attentats
de charlie hebdo que vous connaissez
malheureusement très bien
7 on parlait de nicole belloubet qui a
évoqué la possibilité du retour des
djihadistes finalement pourquoi est ce
que il ya ce revirement selon vous
monsieur league
on a d'abord essayé je crois la
stratégie de la patate chaude
il ya quand même une attaque dans les
2000 personnes qui ont été en
au pays de cham en irak et en syrie dont
il y en a beaucoup qui sont faits
prendre ce qui faisait prendre par les
turcs sauf si c'est pour parler de pure
ce qui faisait prend pas les irakiens
chaque fois c'était différent avec des
gouvernements ou des noms gouvernement
avec lesquels on a des rapports
différents va essayer la stratégie de la
patate chaude
en attendant et en espérant qu'ils se
soient
juger là bas ça ne marche pas créer un
tribunal international spécifique dans
la zone pourquoi pourquoi tu connaisses
états européens ont échoué à créer cette
prison au niveau européen justement pour
les accueillir bush mentionnant manque
de volonté notre pays européens n'ont
peut-être pas envie d'aller chercher des
ennuis
voilà je pense que c'est pas le genre de
choses que l'union européenne sait faire
il est bientôt retirer leurs passeports
à certains de leurs j'ai dit sur ma
rentrée 550 je crois ni à dist
britannique
le gouvernement du canada leur président
et leur passeport ils ne peuvent pas
rentrer dans leur pays
on devrait s'en inspirer je pense j
europe europe europe mais selon quelle
législation ou qui enfin les gens de
nationalités différentes peu geek on y
sera vous avez fait un mur humbert avait
proposé un mur à leur guise la mise
mettant le nazisme du 21e siècle
pourquoi pas créer un mur en banque pour
pouvoir juger
pourquoi vous étiez un tribunal spécial
pour juger les ennemis d'allah
rétroactif localisation c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile mais c'est nécessaire à
laloubère il avait jugé légale bagdadi
si je peux faire la comparaison
les ceux qui ont organisé la solution
finale si on arrivait ils ont
malheureusement laissé filer à son
jugement grande grande partie de ce
qu'ils étaient christophe thévenet la
menace terroriste est toujours bel et
bien là en cinq ans après les attentats
de charlie hebdo
rien que d'ailleurs pour protéger la
rédaction aujourd'hui un million et demi
d'euros par an pour protéger les 45
journalistes qui travaillent aujourd'hui
cinq ans après dans cette rédaction
la menace est toujours présente sur la
menace est présente il faut il faut
saluer leur courage tout simplement
parce que depuis y ait cinq ans ils
vivent
d'une part sous protection policière
pour certains d'entre eux est de toute
façon générale le journal est
aujourd'hui bunkérisé protéger et donc
ils vont imaginer des conditions de
travail
terrible c'est aussi de dire que dans la
vie quotidienne eh ben vous pouvez pas
vous mettre dans une sur une terrasse de
café pour prendre une bière avec des
amis
ça veut dire que toute votre vie du
matin au soir et est marqué par par
cette ce risque permanent et vous parlez
d'un autre risque c'est les fatwas
numérique vous en avez fait une tribune
depuis ces attentats ces fatwas
numérique ou évidemment vous dites la
réponse juridique n'est pas forcément
évidente
c'est la réponse juridique ça consiste à
renvoyer vers ceux qui publient le
contenu la responsabilité de faire le
tri ça veut dire qu'on donne
concrètement à toutes les éditeurs de
réseaux sociaux un devoir de vigilance
lors d'une part vu le volume on sait que
c'est quasi impossible et c'est
quotidien c'est qu'elle est longue si
c'est toi c'est que ces quotidiens ces
quotidiens etc pour toute personne
aujourd'hui qui expriment une opinion
divergente tu veux dire que le la
question dépasse malheureusement
largement le seul le seul journal
charlie hebdo
aujourd'hui toute personne qui exprime
une opinion simplement le fait
d'exprimer une opinion d'exprimer sa
religion ou d'exprimer le fait qu'on est
contre pour telle ou telle religion bien
ça suffit aujourd'hui pour déclencher
effectivement le la colère la haine
alors il ya une loi vous le savez qui en
ce moment est en préparation parlement
pour réglementer cela mais
fondamentalement c'est qui qui peut dire
ce qui est la haine qui peut dire qui
est le message une excellent table on
s'entend que la menace est l appel à la
violence est aujourd'hui la limite on
sait que c'est c'est aujourd'hui une
borne assez évidente admise déjà dans
notre droit
mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya une
forme de contrôle du contenu contre le
moral et qui est aujourd'hui apte à dire
la morale qui est apte à dire si tel ou
tel contenu de par son fonds non pas un
appel à la violence mais simplement par
l'expression d'une opinion mérite ou pas
de rester en ligne mérite ou pas d'être
exprimées lydia games vous connaissez
bien le problème des fatwas numérique 1
souvent on a été vous même victime
comment est ce qu'on vit ces menaces
régulières
c'est très très difficile à vivre au
quotidien il faut faire il faut faire
attention on n'est jamais tout à fait
serein dans la rue quand on quand on se
promène quand on se compte sur son lieu
de travail
quant au rang d'une émission c'est ces
noms c'est très très difficile à vivre
et puis on se retrouve un petit peu seul
très souvent alors il ya il ya quelques
soutiens mais mais concrètement on est
on est seul face à ce déferlement de
haine
il suffit d'exprimer une opinion il
suffit d'exercer son esprit critique
pour pour avoir des milliers de messages
sur les réseaux sociaux d' insulte du
harcèlement et puis des menaces de mort
la semaine dernière la police de
marseille m'appelle pour me faire part
de menaces de mort à mon endroit et à la
police de marseille
parce que c'est ces jeunes chaussée
voilà c'était la base avait été signalée
par par des twitters qui avait été
vigilant et qui avait signalé ces
messages là je sais une personne qui
promettait de venir me chercher chez moi
est bon je passe je passe les détails
et/ou au delà de ça les poursuivre tous
les jours est-ce qu'on va tous les jours
passer une demi journée au commissariat
pour porter plainte comme on peut
comment on peut avoir une activité
professionnelle à côté
si on passe la journée au commissariat
porter plainte c'est des frais de
justice aussi
en face ces personnes sont soutenus
financièrement elles ont les moyens de
pouvoir aller il ya des avocats qui sont
bénévoles
mais pour pour les autres et récemment
je discutais avec des militants laïcs
qui me disent mais comment je vais faire
je n'ai pas les moyens d'avoir un avocat
donc ils se retrouvent il se défend des
valeurs entre carrie versant d'avoir les
risques de défendre la laïcité les
valeurs de la république
notre liberté d'expression et c'est eux
qui se retrouvent seuls et dans la
précarité n'ayant pas les moyens de
pouvoir faire face aux frais de justice
et je trouve que c'est vraiment une
double peine moi j'aimerais je ne sais
pas dans quelle mesure c'est possible
mais j'estime que ces personnes qui ont
une espèce d'impunité sur les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux devraient
exiger
la carte d'identité de ces personnes
pour qu'on est leur identité qu'ils
arrêtent de se cacher comme des lâches
derrière l'anonymat moi je m'exprime
avec mon nom et mon prénom
pourquoi ces personnes qui harcèlent et
qui menacent au quotidien sont derrière
des pseudonymes vous inventer sans cesse
de nouveaux comptes et on n'arrive pas à
aller à les attraper c'est ce qui me
scandalise
est ce qu'il ya un risque réel françois
bernard huyghe de ce passage à l'acte
quand on est menacé sur ses relances on
a tous été injurié nous avec ce que nous
disons ce soir nous allons probablement
nous prendre les moeurs des menaces au
moins au moins de cassage de gueule sur
les réseaux sociaux jouent ça me laisse
tout à fait très tranquille pour le mans
donc il ya là je me tourne vers le jury
a menacé de casser la gueule à quelqu'un
ça tombe sur le logo de droit au moins
citer à lui casser la gueule donc la
législation actuelle suffit les moyens
vous avez parfaitement raison
parce que on est une poignée à se faire
injurier et qui a des tas d'organisation
ou même des ong qui poursuivent les
auteurs de livres
c'est un une disproportion de légères
les condamnations sont son scandale on
la relation pardon de la législation
aujourd'hui c'est patent de réprimer la
lan on l'appelle à la violence est
effectivement vous avez raison ça soit
c'est évidemment sanctionner la question
c'est plutôt de dire comment honda sur
la liberté d'opinion way
parce que quelle que soit l'opinion
c'est un droit fondamental
c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 c'est quelque chose qui
est consubstantielle à une démocratie et
donc la question aujourd'hui avec une
évolution morale où on a cette liberté
d'opinion où elle est garantie et n'a
jamais eu autant protégé par les
décisions de justice
la cour de cassation la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme protège
aujourd'hui véritablement la liberté
d'opinion et le corpus jurisprudentielle
est de ce point de vue là tout à fait
rassurant le problème c'est que la
question se déplacent nous un autre
terrain c'est plus la sanction
judiciaire c'est une sanction qui est
beaucoup plus insidieuse ce sont des
pressions qui sont exercées sur des
rédactions
ce sont des pressions qui sont exercées
très indirectement parfois pour empêcher
l'expression
de quelqu'un c'est pas cette personne là
qui elle-même va faire l'objet de
pressions que ce sont les médias qui
sont là pour relayer cette liberté
d'opinion qui devront se parler
effectivement mais chut je suis d'accord
avec vous d'ailleurs vous enfin pas vous
mais charrie le 10 novembre dernier du
numéro qu'on est passé du nez pour en
parler dans les deux sens de la
patinoire
je voudrais réagir quand même puisque il
y a eu lors de la commémoration de
l'attentât l'hyper cacher il ne faut pas
l'oublier le 9 janvier une protestation
également contre la décision de justice
conduit au sujet du meurtrier présumé de
sarah halimi les actes antisémites ou
non pas forcément diminué non plus
depuis ses 5 ans le fait est ce qu'on
peut corréler c'est la progression des
actes antisémites en tout cas à la
montée de l'islamisme radical bien selon
vous la présence et un est ce que c'est
un terme aux mails sont pas des
partisans l'instant ait plus 74 cents
donc c'est là que se font les actes
racistes antisémites il ya une
augmentation très importante d'autant
plus que l'on considère qu'il faut
concéder que la population juive est
résolument du sort c'est vrai que les
islamistes et le monopole de
l'antisémitisme normal on va toujours à
l'acte pour notre région une extrême
droite identitaire en france qui trouve
ses racines dans l' affaire dreyfus et
chez charles maurras et nos certains
passent à l'acte et dressant des dessine
des croix gammées sur les tombes ou
agressent du mana d'une autre des des
juifs mais je ne fais pas partie des
gens qui n'osent pas dire que il ya une
aggravation de du salafisme vis à vis en
france et que ce sont des gens qui
considèrent que qui refont la guerre
entre israël et la palestine en france
et s'attaque à des ressorts des gens de
religions juive en pensant qu'ils
combattent pour je ne sais quoi pour la
liberté des palestiniens avoir avoir un
état je ne suis pas d'accord avec la
politique des états unis comme comme
beaucoup de gens tapent pas sur les
touristes américains
c'est que c'est quelque chose qui doit
qui doit cesser malheureusement ça
augmente et c'est très étonnant que ça
augmente sans qu'il n'y ait plus de
sanctions et je veux juste rajouter sur
le terrorisme ce qu'on va passer à autre
chose tout à l'heure je n'ai pas fait le
pari que le problème c'est que
on a des officiels qui s'expriment mais
alors qu'il ya des rapports
parlementaires qui considère que
sentinelle par exemple ne sert à rien à
part usées épurées nos militaires et
coûter de l'argent ils le maintiennent
aucun maintien de relations entre l on
appelle un ce sont ces ce sont les
soldats vont chez le papy qui subissent
non mais c'est patrice ennuis sont des
gens qui font des missions l'armée
exemple en termes de moyens ce sont des
gens qui font des missions pendant des
mois et des mois ils ont des problèmes
familiaux bien évident et qu'est ce
qu'on leur dit ah bah non tu veux pas
rentrer chez toi tu vas faire trois mois
de plus à deux balles et dans de paris
dans paris
quand ce sont des professionnels comme
des passes comme les légionnaires se
sert strictement à rien ça assure la
population oui mais pendant ce temps on
fait comme vous l'avez dit on fait des
lois qui ressemble on copie les
américains alors encore quand le
patriote patriotes patriotes ont fait
des lois qui sont liberticides sans que
l'on fasse ce qu'il faut comme on le
disait pour réellement lutter contre le
terrorisme et c'est un vrai vrai
problème restez avec nous on continue ce
débat sur le bilan des attentats de
charlie hebdo et de l'hyper fischer cinq
ans après dans son numéro anniversaire
le directeur de la rédaction du journal
satirique a publié un éditorial sur les
deux nouvelles censures qui menacent
selon lui la liberté d'expression on en
parle dans quelques minutes rester avec
vous
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches consacré cette semaine à vous
prévisions olivier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
on a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine
assez paradoxalement je pense que la
chine est plus dangereux que le diront
je pense qu'on est un pays qui est aux
abois savez quand les pierres se
déclenchent elles se déclenche toujours
parce que les gens ils y ont intérêt à
être 4e prévisions dans le grec cité un
éclatement de la zone euro non moi je
crois pas du tout à un éclatement de la
zone euro et j'attends même avec une
certaine impatience l'entrée de l'ecosse
dans la zone euro alors je ne sais pas
si les causes va rétablir la frontière
est embêté la reine d'angleterre mais en
revanche l'union européenne va avoir
quelques soucis en 2020 mais c'est bien
dit la crise est derrière nous donc oui
il faut donc la crise de l'euro est
derrière nous donc les phéniciens
je sais que pour olivier si ça devait
faire vibrer
[Musique]
mais tous
votre lecture de juristes sur le système
japonais je peux dire que le système
judiciaire japonais est inique que dit
carlos gaudillère dans sa conférence de
presse il explique qu'en réalité ses
avocats le japonais bien sûr ne pouvait
pas lui garantir un procès équitable
c'est dit est ce que cette affaire là
son évasion il ne rend pas service
quelque part au japon
franchement j'y crois pas trop parce
qu'il ya quand même l'effet négatif
c'est à dire je dirais l'humiliation
mais quelque part le départ de carlos
ghosn
indiscutablement leur rend service parce
que cette hypothèque sur l'honneur d'une
justice consistant à ce qu'un procès
soit en réalité l'expression d'une
décision politique
celle d honneur
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs lydia guirous ce georges
kuzmanovic françois bernard huyghe
chercheur associé à l'iris et
spécialiste du terrorisme et de la
communication ainsi que christophe
thévenet avocat à la cour membre du
conseil national du barreau et président
de l'association des amis de charlie
hebdo je rectifie cinq ans après
l'attentât qui a décimé sa rédaction
le journal charlie hebdo s'en prend dans
son spécial de mardi au nouveau gourou
de la pensée formatée
dans son éditorial le directeur de la
rédaction du journal satirique publie
donc un édito où il dénonce les
nouvelles censures vivre est une chance
mais vivre libre est devenu un luxe
écrit-il
elle défendre cette liberté c'est un
message que rice a renouvelé chaque
année
écoutez ça qu'est la liberté de la
presse s'est jamais acquis il ya
toujours des gens qui voudront la
remettre en cause
donc c'est quelque chose qui va se
défendre et se et ses propos et se
revendiquer de toujours voilà c'est
jamais terminé c'est jamais terminé
christophe thévenot défendre la liberté
de la presse
aujourd'hui charlie hebdo le fait tant
bien que mal un est ce que cette presse
est mise à mal aujourd'hui salon du
livre dont je crois le fait bien
ils ne sont pas les seuls la liberté de
la presse c'est le corollaire de deux
choses c'est la liberté d'expression et
c'est la liberté d'opinion à la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'opinion ce
sont des principes qui sont garantis
plus ou moins bien mais de façon
séculaire dans le droit le droit anglais
c'en est préoccupé dès le xvième siècle
donc ça alors soit quelque chose de
nouveau
ce qui est nouveau aujourd'hui c'est que
alors que cette protection existent dans
les textes et nous avons en france
cette loi sur la presse de 1881 qui
revient d'une protection remarquable
nous avons aujourd'hui une jurisprudence
qui est extrêmement bien établie et
auquel richard malka qui est l'avocat en
droit de la presse pour charlie hebdo
depuis des années a contribué
homps nos talons procès des caricatures
aujourd'hui on a on a un corpus qui est
clair on a une jurisprudence qui est
protectrice et on a des magistrats qui
ont effectivement sans porter de
jugement sur le fond qui constate
simplement qu'effectivement les textes
autorisent des choses qui peuvent
paraître très excessive
la cour de cassation vient aujourd'hui
de dans un arrêt récent du mois
d'octobre de dire que nous fait de
représenter marine le pen on est trop
fumant n'étaient pas diffamatoires
alors comment c'est absolument de ce
qu'on veut me font mais si vous dire
qu'effectivement très libéral est large
mais c'est pas sur ce terrain là
aujourd'hui gagné un procès en
diffamation c'est très compliqué ce qui
est aujourd'hui en question c'est le
fait que justement la presse en charge
de relayer cette liberté d'opinion en
charge de finalement de garantir d'une
certaine façon cette liberté
d'expression la presse subit des
pressions et un journaliste qui peut
avoir des pressions les pressions c'est
la pression l'opinion et c'est
dépression économique
un journal qui aurait un journaliste qui
publiera un article qui ne ne plairait
pas à tel ou tel annonceur journal voir
au propriétaire d'un journal c'est vieux
comme le monde sauf que cette pression
là au moment où justement c'est tout le
paradoxe au moment où on a un corpus
jurisprudentielle qui protègent cette
liberté d'opinion a donc assez loin de
l'autre côté on sait très bien que la
faille elle n'est pas là la faille et
l'aide en la possibilité qu'ont
effectivement les journalistes de faire
publier leurs articles d'exprimer leurs
opinions sans se trouver dans une
situation où d'un point de vue
économique
quand ce ne sont pas des pressions plus
physiques qui peuvent être la victime
le plat qui s'expriment mais dans
l'éditorial de risque que j'ai lu je
voudrais qu'on regarde d'abord si vous
le permettez parce que les mouches sont
assez fort et vous réagissez
je m'élève soirée d hier on disait mr
d'adieu à l'armée à l'église et à l'état
aujourd'hui il faut apprendre à dire
merde aux associations tyrannique aux
minorités aux blogueurs et blogueuses
qui nous tape sur les doigts comme des
petits maîtres d'école qui me tape sur
les abolir le jeu que j'approuvais dans
dans son art et qui effectivement alors
charlie c'est une tradition anarchisant
qui se moque des curés des rires des
héros de ceux qui sont en haut que ceux
qui sont en haut punissait de temps en
temps comme au mans la mort du général
de gaulle n'est pas trop cruellement
là ils sont
dans un autre homme qui était
effectivement la pression elle vient
d'un tas d'associations d'un tas d'os
ong d'organisation en ligne qui s'adapte
paca charles il ya une organisation qui
s'attaque à des annonceurs publicitaires
qui publierait dans des qui ferait des
annonces dans des dents les organes trop
à droite ou trop à gauche et c'est donc
il ya une pression par les qui peut se
faire par les tweets par les menaces etc
et d'autre part il me semble qu'il ya
une complaisance à toutes ces ces
stigmatisations ces interdictions ses
malédictions convoi régner par exemple
sur les plateaux de télévision pas celui
ci à l'évidence à l'occasion des 50
charlie où on explique que oui mais
quand même ils ont insulté l'ag religion
c'est pas si bien que ça et puis ça sent
un peu la faute bill slam aux phobies
lâchez pas quoi phobie à tirano des
minorités non aux rites et soutenue par
des des orcades et raison sur son htc
pour le gendarme qui font craindre c'est
là on n'est pas en france mais aux états
unis mais à tel point que le new york
times après la publication d'une d'un
dessin de presse a décidé de de
carrément de ne plus jamais diffusés
vous voyez c'est ce dessin qui a fait
réagir qui a été qualifié d' antisémite
ou on voit benyamin netanyahu tenu en
laisse en forme de chien par par donald
trump pour critiquer la politique au
proche orient
il ya plus de dessins de presse
maintenant dans le new york times s'est
terminée cette régression c'est une
régression c'est un manque de courage
une caricature doit déranger une
caricature doit provoquer elle doit
mettre peut-être même mal à l'aise mais
ça doit provoquer le débat donc charlier
2 si on n'est pas à l'aise avec une
union regarde ailleurs
mais c'est leur devoir c'est ça une
caricature et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une je le disais c'est
l'auto sera ni des minorités qui amène à
une autocensure des journalistes qui
amènerait une autocensure des auteurs
moi j'en sais quelque chose en tant
qu'auteur aujourd'hui quand vous voulez
publier vous avez des gens qui vous
relie zh alors c'est pas comme aux états
unis avec les sensitive reader mais qui
sont là pour voir c'est un nouveau
métier là c'est ça
mais lille était le scénario pour ne pas
heurter la sensibilité des minorités et
qu'on la laisse agir qui pourrait la
réécrire et vent levé les passages c'est
la fin de l'esprit critique c'est la fin
de la pensée c'est la fin de la
littérature
alors vous avez quand même quelques
pressions quand quand vous êtes auteur
et sur les sujets de lutte contre le
communautarisme on vous dit cela relève
à suivre particulièrement village ans à
attentionné non-tissé large pardon c'est
pas simplement le problème de l'islam
c'est tout simplement de dire que les
barrières aujourd'hui qui sont mis en
terme de morale sont des barrières qui
touchent absolument tout un repas tous
les sujets des tirs est sûre c'est à
dire que soit le sujet vous aurez
quelqu'un qui vous dira je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est son droit mais qui va le
dire de façon extrêmement violente sur
les réseaux sociaux et internet
ce débat n'est plus un débat dans la
presse qui est encadrée comme nice fait
c'est un débat sur des réseaux sociaux
qui est relayée avec des messages qui
sont effectivement parfois extrêmement
violents
on avait bataillé après les attentats
pour protéger certains des membres de la
de la rédaction qui voyaient leurs
adresses personnelles publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux avec les obtenir de
twitter obtenir d'eux des réseaux
sociaux le nettoyage de ses fils de
tweets pour retirer ces messages ça a
été en soit difficile c'est la réalité
si vous voulez c'est que quelle que soit
l'opinion vous exprimer aujourd'hui
j'aurais évidemment la condamnation mais
que cette contradiction n'est plus sur
des supports on connaissait qui étaient
les supports des médias traditionnels et
s'exprime aujourd'hui de façon
complètement désorganiser complètement
déstructuré sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui n'est devenu extrêmement difficile
de vouloir contrôler de vouloir
interdire et encore une fois acquis de
faire est ce que ce sont les éditeurs
est-ce que c'est twitter france qui doit
s'ériger en gendarme dire ça oui ça non
est ce que ce sont derrière des
magistrats mais le temps de la justice
n'est pas celui des médias c'est des
réseaux sociaux
on a un décalage qui rend cette cette
sanction judiciaire malheureusement
existe mais elle est réelle et
inopérante
c'est ça aujourd'hui le débat georges
kuzmanovic est ce qu'on veut finalement
on a vu un dans son édito hier on disait
mr d'adieu à l'armée voilà bon c'était
on avait est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout
aujourd'hui est ce que le sens de
l'humour finalement quel qu'il soit en a
pris un coup
oui clairement c'est intéressant de
faire des rétrospectives de desproges ou
polak où les hommes les inconnus ou
rouler ou les nuls et j'avais vu le jour
au spectacle des nuls mais il serait
interdit ou deux au deuxième épisode de
certains films aussi par toute une série
d'associations effectivement dès qu'ils
seraient qui se sentiraient choqué que
ce soit une association une religieuse
de genre de relations sexuelles
politiques mais et vous avez récemment
ses problèmes de pression a d'abord eu
de problème de pression économique et
qui sous la macro ni se développe de
manière assez assez terrifiante j'en
veux pour preuve très récemment j'avais
réagi ici sur le incendie qui avait été
fait d'un péage à narbonne et une
fonction très long pour le conte à une
manifestation des filets jauger les
jaunes 21 gilet jaune dont un jeune de
29 ans qui prend cinq ans bon pour du
matériel et j'évoquais budgétaire ainsi
et que monsieur macron veut vendre les
aéroports de paris à vinci et que la
justice était trouvé très très rapide à
s'exécuter sur ces gilet jaune comme ce
jour mille autres qui sont en prison et
que monsieur vinolas qui lui fait des
exactions un peu avant l'attentât les
problèmes économiques mais dans des
journaux je publie régulièrement les
journalistes sur le fond ça très très
bien mais ils m'ont dit ainsi à vous
pour la douceur c'est trop rude alors
que je suis apte à vendin externe
politique vous êtes inquiets sont
publiés c'est trop c'est trop compliqué
alors sa mort n'a fait de manifestations
en france contre jeudi dernier que nous
on a été attaquée parce qu'on attaque et
sur les réseaux sociaux par des gens qui
considèrent qu'avoir une cocarde est un
fasciste nazi
nous on détruit notre barground devant
devant les policiers et ils sont
soutenus en cela sur des réseaux sur les
réseaux sociaux par toute une série de
senseurs et donc là il sur les réseaux
sociaux se transpose dans la rue et
finalement m prend elle prend oui je
prends deux exemples mais si vous êtes
journaliste effectivement comme le 10e
on avait déjà la star ac et l'as mandé
policiers peuvent pas être derrière tout
le monde
alors les journalistes de charlie hebdo
son protégé mais effectivement peut-être
pas tout le temps ça se trouve il ya
moins ils ont des vacances ils vont
prendre un pot je sais pas une terrasse
d'un café ou et juillet quand ils seront
en vacances ils sont il ya des risques
et son protégé aussi quand c'est oui
tout le temps donc c'est du 24 24 ans
devrait encore une fois tout le monde
peut pas être protégé tout le temps
partout et ses censeurs sur les réseaux
créés ad et on les crée des situations
très très hauts revenus c'est à des
problèmes réels d'expression on va
écouter le un ancien rédacteur en chef
de fluide glacial qui lui est un
dessinateur et qui opère à bruxelles
écoutez par le fait d attente a eu un
focus sur notre métier mais finalement
avec ce focus il ya eu une déferlante de
critiques tout est passé sous les
fourches caudines des réseaux sociaux on
peut plus faire un dessin moi je suis
pas toujours d'accord à tes dessins de
charlie mais faut pas oublier que
charlie est un hebdo si on n'est pas
d'accord on critique que nathan la
semaine suivante
là on voit des dessins qui survivent
pendant des mois et des mois sur des
réseaux qui vont en iran qui vont aux
états unis et puis finalement ça fait
tâche d'huile on voit que le new york
times ce finalement arrête de faire des
dessins de presse parce que il ya trop
de réactions sur un seul dessin qui
partent de netanyahou donc à journal dit
on risque plus d'avoir des peu plus
risqué d'avoir des critiques de masse on
arrête le dessin de presse parce qu'ils
sont complètement paradoxale g11
confrères du canard enchaîné quand ils
représentent par exemple une femme qui
fait la vaisselle et le mec qui boivent
un verre de rouge
eh ben le canard enchaîné reçoit des
centaines de courriers de lecteurs parce
qu'on n'a plus le droit de représenter
une femme qui fait la vaisselle par
exemple et donc on sait plus où s'arrête
et avec ça il ya la fameuse polémique
autour de disney on peut plus montrer le
prince charmant qui embrasse la
princesse parce que c'est quasiment du
viol donc et cette espèce de censure qui
s'est dit lui
les réseaux sociaux dans une espèce de
doxa effectivement ça remplace une
censure d'état comme si le peuple avait
besoin d'une censure permanente voie à
une censure permanente c'est la question
que nous aimons plus souvent plus la
censure que la liberté des échecs petit
mais ce qui a chargé dans cette censure
c'est qu'elle ne se fait plus au nom de
principes de la religion du comportement
des bons pères de famille en or qu'elle
soit très idéologique etc mais de normes
supérieures que devrait respecter un bon
citoyen mais au long d'une subjectivité
total je suis une femme vous montrer une
femme en train de faire la vaisselle
vous insultez toutes les femmes
je suis de telle couleur etc vous
répondez un préjugé sur les gros les
juifs les arabes les arrête pas
puisqu'on a une créance infini pour
empêcher l'autre de dire quoique ce
devient formateur au nom de la pensée de
conserver la 70e ya 70 ans le x clay
l'auteur du meilleur des mondes à avis
est cette phrase moi que je trouve les
meneuses en disant que la dictature la
plus parfaite ressemblerait à la
démocratie c'est à dire un système où
les gens ont la liberté mais ils ont
peur de l'utiliser
c'est comme si vous vous ouvrez la cage
d'un animal et cet animal refuserait de
sortir de profiter de la liberté qu'on
lui propose
nous en sommes là c'est à dire que
l'auto censure ou sept sont sur un
direct où on vous explique quand vous
avez fait une tribune qu'on va peut-être
pas la passer parce que n'est ce pas ça
pourrait contrarier
on est effectivement à se dire que
finalement dans ce pays de liberté de
liberté réaffirmé protégés par la loi et
par les juges
eh bien on en est à refuser de s'en
saisir le message je crois de charlie
hebdo c'est qu'il faut avoir la volonté
le courage de s'en saisir et on sait
qu'on se met à risque
ce faisant on sait que quelle que soit
l'opinion que vous exprimer que ce soit
d'ailleurs une opinion pro-islamiste
proféministes roffit ce que vous voulez
de toute façon ce faisant vous vous
mettez à risque et vous risquez elle a
immédiatement eu ton
la nation sur les réseaux sociaux on
vous risquez peut-être même des
procédures judiciaires
heureusement celle-ci aujourd'hui ce se
termine finalement de façon assez
protectrices de notre liberté
mais derrière on se retrouve avec des
gens qui simplement n'osent pas exprimer
et le message c'est de dire il faut
avoir le courage de le faire et vous
savez la liberté ne s'use que si l'on ne
s'en sert pas 1
elle ya gagné et georges kiejman ovi
chat oui en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on
va vers une américanisation de la
société où chaque minorité les minorités
au sein des minorités finalement cette
diversité est ce multiculturalisme vers
lequel on va même si on essaye tous deux
de se battre pour la république une et
indivisible pour universaliser
malheureusement force est de constater
que les communautés s'installer le
multiculturalisme gagne du terrain et
j'ai l'impression que le pendant de tout
ça finalement c'est une régression de la
pensée une régression de l'esprit
critique une régression de la liberté
sous couvert de bien pensants ce à titre
d'exemple les missions de zemmour
l'émission de zemmour sur une autre
chaîne
on aime ou on aime pas et mourront
partage ou pas ses idées et meaux a tout
de même le droit de s'exprimer à la
télévision française dont on ne doit pas
qu'ils restent dans l'oeil scott dans le
respect de la loi bien sûr on ne doit
pas appeler au boycott de son émission
on a droit de l'abricot tous les noms
mais alizé âgées ce que je veux dire
c'est surtout les oui mais c'est surtout
ce que je voulais dire ce sont ces ses
appels aux annonceurs pour dire ne fait
plus de publicité pour l'émission d'eric
zemmour
une façon de tuer économiquement son
émission mais si on était véritablement
dans dans le courage est encore dans le
débat et dans la liberté d'expression il
faut aller débattre face à eric zemmour
instruments vous immergeant intéressé
parce que finalement réaliser certaines
personnes et ce qu'on leur donne pas et
évidemment de l'importance dans mes en
démêler blick
et en plus on ne fait pas avancer le
débat on ne démonte pas les arguments
d'eric zemmour si on n'est pas d'accord
avec lui on le laisse prospérer et
je trouve que c'est c'est vraiment une
régression ne s'arrêtera pas là on
attaque les annonces officielles 2 et
moi on a commencé à attaquer les
annonceurs le lycée à l'heure actuelle
le prochain c'est qui c'est l'express
délirant on a quand même attaqué henri
peña ruiz ce qu'il avait dépassé on est
quand même chez les fous rires pays
communiste qui est qu'elle a visités ces
défenseurs de la laïcité
bien sûr des frontières assiste alors
oui maintenant c'est mal parce qu'il
débat avec quelqu'un rencontre là là là
c'est vraiment et 80 dans l'addiction et
la comparaison que l'estonie est juste
un vrai drame en france s'est essayée
s'est accélérée en quelques années même
si le communautarisme qui s'installe à
tous les à toutes les échelles de la
société et c'est vraiment pas la france
et c'est très risqué vu notre passé et
les guerres de religion mais le
parallèle avec les états unis s'arrête
là parce que là bas et eux ils ont le
premier amendement équipe merci vous
pouvez à peu près dit absolument
n'importe quoi alors en france on a
effectué nous on a des lois mémorielles
à l'annoncé on a des protection du
secret des affaires tanguera plus en
plus fins et la masse et expire cette
fois pas de souvenir qu'on s'inspire du
tout voilà moi personnellement je
préfère le sait des choses que je
j'apprécie aux etats unis c'est le
premier amendement est plus laissant
dire les imbéciles et leur folie de
toute façon il reste dans marca c'est si
les arguments chose qui à l'époque les
mais les références et les spectacles
aussi qu'ils sont les justes version
dernière chose il ya un glissement très
court où il ya très très court c'est le
glissement au moment de charlie hebdo il
ya cinq ans au moins d'attentats il ya
eu quand même
nationalement une émotion et les gens
sont descendus l'esprit service est
vraiment resté die mais là il ya un
glissement à l'époque avec quelques
personnes qui sont moqués et qui ont dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas avec dans cette
ferveur nationale pour défendre la
liberté d'expression ya un glissement en
cinq ans ou c'est plutôt ceux qui sont
contre la liberté d'expression qui ont
gagné du terrain
ils ont ils ont regagné du terrain et
ils ont aujourd'hui effectivement ne
semble aussi que certains plateaux télé
vous citez des plateaux où zemmour peut
s'exprimer
c'est aussi la recherche d'un buzz
finalement on cherche l'affrontement
plus que une réflexion de fond on
propose aux gens qu l'achat spectacle de
gladiateurs et et non plus un spectacle
qui vise à à remonter le niveau
ces villas les premières victimes je
crois de cette situation ce sont tout
simplement les toutes les formes
d'expression de la culture bien sûr la
pièce de théâtre de charb aujourd'hui a
du mal à être représentés aujourd'hui
vous invitez tel mais bel et bien à
d'entrée avant même qu'ils aient eu le
moindre mot prononcé vous allez avoir
des demandes d'interdiction de
représentation d'une pièce de théâtre de
projection d'un film car il s'agit avant
le 20ème par exemple il s'agit pas de
condamner le lait le fond encore une
fois le droit de dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec le fait que mais
aujourd'hui on n'a plus la possibilité
de véritablement protéger ceux qui
veulent s'exprimer c'est à dire que les
lieux où la culture ou le pluralisme et
où la liberté d'opinion peut s'exprimer
bien ces lieux aujourd'hui sont de plus
en plus difficilement accessible et on a
vu des conférences qui ont été
perturbées ces gars skient donc
extrémistes
on ne peut plus au débat qui devait
parler de la pma voilà c'était c'est la
façon de faire aujourd'hui de la
violence quand on ne veut pas entendre
des discours
c'est ce cri différence de la pensée
unique c'est la crim pensée d'orwell
dans 1984 mail s'instaure en douceur et
ont intériorisé
il n'y a pas besoin de l'écran une
police pour l'imposer et vous l'avez
également dans les partis politiques
quand vous traitez de certains sujets
avec clarté en refusant le déni vous dit
attention c'est clivant attention ça
peut baptiser un stylet spécial hiver et
intérêts selon vous trek ou non là je
revendique l esprit charlie je pense
qu'il faut l'avoir en étendard parce que
c'est l'esprit de la liberté mais il va
mal il va mal et notamment auprès des
plus jeunes et c'est ça qui est le plus
inquiétant
je pense que nos aînés ont cette volonté
de chérir 7,7 liberté d'expression de
sheridan inconnu et sas qui l'ont connu
parce qu'ils savent ce que c'est que de
ne pas l'avoir mais chez les plus jeunes
esprits charlie va très mal et je crois
même qu'ils aient une forme de roger
parce qu'ils sont déjà dans le
multiculturalisme et dans l'axé nord-sud
sous les signes de redressement de la
fin pour vous pour moi le mot de la fin
c'est de dire que nous avons tous cette
responsabilité de permettre le débat et
nous devons tous avoir le courage de
dire le débat doit exister
l'autocensure je pense c'est ce qu'il ya
de pire et permettre un système de
s'installer vous ne pourrez plus parler
on n'a plus les espaces là oui c'est
très inquiétant
et là le risque aujourd'hui c'est de
voir que ces espaces de liberté que
charlie blues dans un bunker que ma foi
les journaux la presse des endroits où
on peut s'exprimer libyen librement va
ce sont des espaces qui ce qui se
restreignent qui se contracte et ça
c'est ça c'est très inquiétant c'est la
culture il s'est finalement là la voix
de l'homme qui qui qui disparaît merci
beaucoup c'est l'heure du coup de gueule
à présent
[Musique]
et on commence par vous lydia guirous ça
un coup de gueule pour une iranienne
médaillé olympique qui a décidé de
quitter son pays
alors plutôt un coup de coeur pour elle
et un coup de gueule contre tous ceux
qui défendent le voile islamique en nous
disant que c'est parti de la liberté
c'est qu'ils me alice ali zadeh qui
était champion de sa seule femme
championnes olympiques de taekwondo
d'iran beaucoup la prenaient en exemple
pour dia m'a regardé les championnes
olympiques et elle porte le voile c'est
finalement un signe de liberté et
d'émancipation pour les femmes
et cette femme a quitté l'iran en disant
qu'elle qu'elle en avait assez d'être
instrumentalisés qu'elle en avait assez
des pressions de cette oppression aussi
et de cette obligation de porter le
voile que le régime iranien impose aux
femmes et donc je voulais saluer son
courage et c'est aussi un pied de nez
finalement à tous ceux qui nous disent
que le voile n'est pas un symbole
d'oppression et qui utilise souvent ces
femmes championne olympique pour essayer
de nous l'imposer
ici on note une liberté d voyez donc que
ce soit les iniques militante du
féminisme islamique le féminisme
islamique ça n'existe absolument pas où
leurs idiots utiles qui l'est qui les
soutiennent je rappelle quand même que
le féminisme s'est construit en
opposition à la religion donc voila et
donc je voulais vraiment saluer son
courage et dire à tous ceux qui
soutiennent les les femmes militantes du
voile de finalement se taire et pour
vous georges kiejman au beach à un coup
de gueule sur le projet de loi qui a été
présenté le projet de loi sur les
retraites bien sûr qui a été présentée
cette semaine par le gouvernement alors
un élément parce que c'est
l'articulation crible voilà oui elle a
passé au crible on a des enfants on a
débattu vendredi 140 cent quarante et
une page est un élément central qui
montre la tactique et la logique du
gouvernement c'est les 26 26 référence
26 référence à l'article 38 quand je lis
qui de la constitution qui permet de
prendre des mesures qui sont normalement
du ressort de la loi donc un signal
clair du gouvernement ça veut dire que
signalons qu'un débat et encore il ya
même pas besoin car ça permet
d'accélérer la mise en place de mesures
qui ne sont pas réellement
décréter devrait parler ça va permettre
au gouvernement de faire passer toute
une série de choses qui ne sont pas
compréhensibles et qu'il a fait exprès
de ne pas rendre compréhensible aux
français en attendant que il aura 18
mois pour le faire quand ce sera votée
alors en attendant que le mouvement
social s'essouffle et donc c'est ça sa
stratégie donc mal malheureusement la
cfdt et l'unsa pensent qu'ils ont
remporté une victoire qui n'ont eux qui
est une victoire à la pyrrhus
ils sont mais qu'il ne serrerait une
fois qu'ils ont l'air un peu d'une vraie
victoire
voilà c'est pas une victoire et j'avais
tout le monde a continué tout ce qu'ils
peuvent a continué ce mouvement de grève
et de résistance à cette loi qui saborde
un grand acquis de la république
française on va en parler bien sûr un
discours dans les prochains un pôle it
mag c'est la fin de cette émission merci
georges cuisse banovic merci lydia
guirous ce merci françois bernard huyghe
et merci christophe je venais d'avoir
participé à ce débat va rester avec nous
sur sur rt france
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]